a lot of that stuff it seems like
everything works out too much like it's
scripted yeah like during during Trump's
campaign I kept saying he's got a win I
go this doesn't play if he doesn't win
this isn't rocky won this has to be
rocky - he's got a [ __ ] win it's not
about the battle and the bravery and
that he's got to win this for this to
work to really highlight the theater of
the right right he's gotta win yes
[ __ ] one theater of the absurd I mean
that guy president with his fake hair
skin with the white around the eyes it
all seems so fake everything he says he
says the way he looks like yet
everything is insane I still every time
I see him walking down the stairs Air
Force One I'm just like holy [ __ ] Donald
Trump is the president like what what
kind of wacky world of really wacky
world luckily wacky yeah the other day i
ibly wacky world when he was given that
speech about elvis and it's just like
people telling me I looked like Elvis
that's it but people have told me if I
wasn't blond I look like Elvis and and
it's like no one told you that no one
ever told you that maybe your belly
right when if Elvis was sitting on the
ball for the last time but that's about
it how about when that reporter
confronted him look at the two of them
together picture people tell me I look
like the King maybe oh my god a little
bit about the upper right hand corner
one have you have you ever seen anyone
trap anyone of course
thousand memes now yeah have you ever
seen someone so committed to a comb-over
for so many years like so committed it's
not just a coma it's I don't know what
addition it's a Yankee contraption
walking up the stairs of Air Force One
where the winds
when it behind you see the whole back of
his head is bald yeah where's the hair
coming from it was like a [ __ ]
Vader's head without the helmet it kind
of looked like that weird like what's
going on you never know where it's
starting and where it ends and how long
it is it's like look at that oh my god
that's just a picture the the video is
more disturbing because you see the
flops yeah yeah chaos
well how about you know he didn't want
to go out there for the 4th of July
memorial because he didn't want to get
his hair wet his hair wet in the rain
that was a yeah that's what they were
saying what I don't know that is such a
weird thing like he it was a set of
September 11th that's what it was
the president 9/11 was a Veterans Day
isn't it like that the president is is a
guy that's so like insecure yeah that
forever for decades he has to [ __ ] do
a [ __ ] Dairy Queen ice cream [ __ ]
move on his head every day so he's fat
like if you yeah the thing is like if
you're really concerned so much about
your looks or high why are you fat like
why at it I don't think he thinks he's
fat I think he's like one of those guys
that you talked about having a body
dysmorphia
body dysmorphia they just he looks in
the mirror and sees Elvis like young
leather-clad Elvis yeah he's got this
weird thing you know where he doesn't
believe in exercise because he feels
like the body is like a battery and if
you put any energy and it's gonna wear
it wears it out well the [ __ ] is
up at all hours the dirt during the
campaign for the midterms he was doing
three rallies a day flying all over the
country and he never seemed to be like
he was falling asleep or losing energy
so I don't know what he's doing well do
you know about all that he says I get
exercise I mean I walk I this I that
Trump 71 said during the Oval Office I
run over to a building next door
I get more exercise than people think I
run over to a building that's amazing my
exercise is incredible he's on allegedly
according to one reporter he's on diet
pills and he's been on diet pills
forever and then there's a prescription
that they mean
he actually even cited the exact duane
reade pharmacy where he was supposed to
take this for like a little while he
went up taking it for years i was taking
some form of amphetamines oh good for
him in this day and age you would be
[ __ ] stunned if you found out how
many journalists how many people who are
writers how many people that are
professionals how many people that work
or on adderall oh yeah I'm in I mean I
live in an area where there's a lot of
people that have money and they work
real hard and because of the fact that
they need energy I know a shitload of
people that are taking adderall yeah
folks that are in Hollywood folks that
are in finance all sorts of different
yeah I know quite a few also yeah they
it's everywhere man
I mean it's it is such a you know the
difference between methamphetamine and
amphetamines the difference in meth and
what you're getting when you get
adderall is so goddamn close yeah yeah
so close but math it's crazy yeah you
take that you're [ __ ] you're a meth
head the only difference is how quick it
hits you yeah literally the only
difference and then the dosage that you
get is obviously regulated to forget
adderall
right right I don't know I I'm not I'm
not a pill guy I never have been what do
you got here Jamie we pulling up it says
here about being on a treadmill Oh
awesome I was on a treadmill for the
first time actually in quite a while and
it was a very steep angle and I was
there for a very long time he said they
were surprised and they said well you
can stop now that's amazing and I said I
can go much longer than this if you want
me to hey Trump I got a [ __ ] right
now buddy I got a challenge how about
you join the silver October fitness
challenge man hop on we'll put that
strap on you we'll see what's up see
who's amazed everything is over the top
with Trump it's dieted successfully
before have been more of a believer in
diet cuz I'm strong you know I've always
been more of a believer in diet cuz I'm
strong you know hit the ball far I mean
I'm strong physically he said that is so
hilarious
will you imagine wrestling him how weak
you must feel just a bag of
jellow just smush it's all cushy
the bones are barely held together a
thread what are you talking about your
story is far I'm strung I mean when he
said that he would beat up Joe Barden
that was my though that was like yeah
peak ludicrousness yeah yeah it's like
what you're gonna beat up to Hugh Joe
Biden would go down fast and hard that's
what he said dude the fact that they're
talking like that again absurd it's so
[ __ ] funny that well and Biden has
said the same thing like he ha kick his
ass he's a blade
when did they dig Truman and Dewey trade
barbs like that back in the day is what
is he saying Nixon and Kennedy they
asked me what I like to debate this
gentleman I said no I said if we were in
high school I'd take you behind the gym
and beat the hell out of them meanwhile
I don't believe that I think Trump would
kick his ass
I really do Trump is meaner and I think
Biden would make a mistake yeah Trump
better behave it uh he would swing and
he would slip and he would fall and he'd
[ __ ] his knee up and trumpet kick him in
the face like a soccer ball he would get
lucky and he would walk away and Biden
would be holding his teeth and blood
coming out of his mouth anybody told you
in the best the best ever